Speaker 1: Florida Republicans are now looking
to push the state's 15 week abortion ban to a
six week abortion ban. And a few of you wrote
to me and said, David, this bill doesn't make
any sense. Women often don't know that they're
pregnant before the six week mark, but that is
exactly why it makes perfect sense to the people
who are trying to completely ban abortion. It is
a feature of this proposal that many women don't
know. They're pregnant before the six month mark,
not a bug. And we are going to discuss that
in more detail. The New York Times New York
Times reports Florida Republicans propose a six
week abortion ban. The bills would tighten the
current 15 week limit and offer narrow exceptions.
Governor Ron DeSantis said he welcomed, quote,
pro-life legislation. There is very little that is
pro-life about this bill. If a ban passes, right.
David Chen and Patricia Mosey for The New York
Times. If a ban passes and is signed into law by
DeSantis, Florida would prohibit abortion before
many women even realize they are pregnant. The
bills had been telegraphed for weeks. Republican
leaders who controlled Tallahassee sought to build
on the anti-abortion momentum generated by the
US Supreme Court's overturning of Roe v Wade.
DeSantis, expected to run for president, said he
supports additional restrictions, but the bills
offer a reminder of the political complexities
that he must navigate. Abortion restrictions
appeal to Republicans, but 64% of Florida
residents believe abortion should be legal in
most or all cases. Now, that's actually you know,
this is a bigger trend with abortion in general,
which is that if you go back to the start of the
Roe v Wade era, you find that today rather than a
month ago, rather than a year ago today, support
for abortion being legal in most cases is higher
than it has been at any time during that Roe v
Wade era. And so although the anti-abortion stuff
is useful for raising money from certain pieces of
the electorate, it's useful for playing red meat
games and throwing red meat out to supporters.
In practice, when you talk to Americans, although
there are still many Americans, of course, tens
of millions who are just against any abortion
at any time period, For the most part, Americans
believe abortion should be legal in most cases.
And so there is a political complexity.
But let's talk about the six week thing.
This is the critical aspect to this as a de facto
way to just ban abortion completely. Why? Well,
pregnant women are considered to be four weeks
pregnant by the time they miss their period.
Often that's the first sign of pregnancy. Now,
another thing that's important to to remember
is how closely any particular woman would be
tracking. This does depend on whether she's trying
to be pregnant or not. And we'll sort of get to
that. But the first day of your last period is
technically day one of the pregnancy. If you have
a 28 day cycle, which is sort of like the average,
so you're already four weeks pregnant at the
point at which you suspect you might be missing
your period. If you're not actively trying to
conceive, you may not realize you're pregnant
within the two weeks that are left after the miss
period. And miss periods can mean nothing. Right.
There could be a plus or minus seven days or
something like that. So now you're at five weeks,
but the limit is six weeks. I know people who did
IVF, in vitro fertilization, they were tracking.
They were monitoring everything. They didn't know
they were pregnant until what would have been five
weeks into the pregnancy. Most Obies won't even
see a patient for a new pregnancy until the eight
week mark unless you're having fertility issues
and they say, Come in, we're going to do an h, c,
g. I believe it is blood test to figure out what's
going on and check the level. So by this point,
you were you would no longer legally be able to
get an abortion in the state of Florida. That's
the point. And so normal people would say, oh,
that makes it really difficult to get an abortion
at all. That doesn't make sense. The people who
want the bill are saying, oh, that will make it
really difficult to get an abortion at all. That's
exactly what we want without outright banning
abortion. So this is something that Florida
Republicans are pushing. We're going to continue
seeing this in other states. Some states have
really old laws that were that are still in place,
but that weren't relevant because of Roe v Wade
existence with the removal of Roe v Wade. Now,
those laws are once again being revived
and evaluated from a state Supreme Court
standpoint in some states. So this is all going to
get worse and worse and worse. Now, quite frankly,
I don't think Republicans at the federal level
are really going to be running on this because
they know the numbers. And in fact, I may be
wrong, but in this nascent stage of his candidacy,
I don't think I've heard Trump talk about abortion
almost ever. And much of the focus when it comes
to the social and cultural issues has been on
transgender issues. And we've been talking about
that and covering it. So we'll see where this
goes in Florida. We'll zoom out. And in a year,
we will see where the abortion landscape is.
But it is absolutely scary and horrifying stuff.